[Music]
all through the night you're shining
bright i'm your host the baby you're my
pearl
[Music]
hello
dominic darling i love the fact that we
started with complete silence how's it
going look at my t-shirt i'm very good
welcome if you would ladies and
gentlemen to this week's the friendship
onion was dominating motherhood and
billy boy this is that's a fantastic
t-shirt yeah this is me just gently
stroking my pectoral muscles whilst
framing the friendship onion t-shirt
around it if you guys want a more
uh worthwhile thorough look
here is the thorough version of t-shirt
available at the merchandise store at
the friendship onion podcast.com
get your t-shirts your mugs and all
sorts of things all available at the
friendship onionpodcast.com
william i wondered if maybe we wanted to
start with a song this week and my
little proviso to that was
maybe i could do
one part of the song and you could do
another and we could go backwards and
forwards because there's a break in the
song and i want to find out if you know
the melody of the break
so are you ready
what song are we doing
i'm just going to go with it you know it
don't worry if you don't know it i'll
i'll fill you in but i'll do the first
bit you do the next bit and then i'll
leave you to do the break because i want
to see if you know the break are you
ready
carry on we'll try it we'll try it let's
all right here we go so the song starts
like this right
now
[Music]
da
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
da
i was just curious because a lot of
people
know that no
and as you know dom the dance routine
for the first part
i think you're right that's the birdie
song right but what do you do
what what dance do you do in the other
bed the no no
if anyone knows if you don't know dom if
anyone else do you know i don't know but
i should know because i believe that the
birdie song is a classic german song
it yeah i think so
dom
if anyone knows the dance that you do
during the na nan and please write in to
the friendship onion
at castmedia.com or leave a voicemail on
what's that called again dom you do that
one pipe forward slash
friendshiponyon.com
maybe
speakpike.com
forward slash the friendship on you is
that right brilliant i mean that's great
or you can leave messages all over our
social media it's one of them just leave
messages
right guys it's the busiest time of year
we all know that but if you need a break
from the holiday action best fiends is
the perfect pick-me-up i play on my
phone it's fantastic it's seriously my
new favorite game best fiends is a max 3
style puzzle and adventure game all
rolled into one and you can play it
anywhere if you don't have a wi-fi
connection no problem play best fiends
wherever and whenever you want with
offline mode and uh dom
as you know i might not be the greatest
gamer but i'm already up a few levels
i'm doing pretty good and it literally
has thousands of levels so there's
always something if you need a little
mental pick me up download best fiends
free today on the app store or google
play that's friends without the our
best fiends
anyway we've got a lot to do today
brilliant so we should crack on i think
we've got a couple of voicemails which
are going to be sent to us via johnny
close hit it johnny cruz hey
play the button johnny cluj
hey guys this is garrison from uh
tennessee here in the states uh first of
all big fan of you guys um grew up
watching lord of the rings uh probably
my favorite all-time
trilogy just absolutely love it obsessed
um
and thank you so much for doing this
podcast i have thoroughly enjoyed
hearing you guys uh talk about your
experiences on and off camera just it's
really cool to be able to see the
conversations between any relationship
between each other
it's really enjoyable to listen to you
guys
um but yeah my question is
pertaining to lord of the rings
what would be
i guess your favorite
shot throughout the entire all three
movies um just something that never
failed to like i guess give you
goosebumps or just just really
just like the the camera angle or
whatever the music whatever about that
scene the acting uh that just really
made you go wow and every time you watch
it it's just
like i said goosebumps um
mine would have to be probably the scene
where you
two are riding on a tree bird's back
doing the last march of the ends heading
towards eisenguard about to fight
great scene
ah makes me want to tear up every time i
see it um it's it's great
um but yeah thank you guys so much hope
you have a great rest of your day
and thanks bye fantastic good good good
question dom
yeah that was that was a nice one the
march of the empty
brilliant great to be involved in that
um can i answer this one just now dom
please be my guest
so it's it's not one that
it's one that
as a viewer
i mean i like the show but mainly it's
the memory
of what happened that day that i really
enjoy
is there's a scene
in gondor when pippin and gandalf
arrive at the you know the great city of
minnesota
and we're walking uh past the tree of
gondor which has been dead for years
because of all the evil in the world etc
and um
pippin notices a flower
uh just starting to uh bloom on the tree
of gondor so it's it's alive again and
there's hope
and
i remember
there was a
huge crane
on on that shot so it kind of followed
me and ian mckellen down and then it
went on to the tree and then and then it
picked up
to a huge you know
uh shot of menace teres
there
which was you know this beautiful big
city kind of
showing into the rocks of a mountain
uh
and i remember watching it back like we
did the scene and then i ran back to
look at it on the tv next to pete
jackson and he says you see this this
this is when you know it's a movie
and then because of the you know this
crane shot they never do that on tv them
they might find a way to do it now with
their drones and stuff but i remember at
that time thinking oh yeah this is like
you know
this is a big film we we take this day
just to basically get that shot and it's
worthwhile because it's there forever
you know yeah so that's your always
rings in my mind because of what pete
said you know rather than the actual
shop
just to clarify when you say
big crane
you mean the mechanical
device not the bird
no i think there was some scenes where
they did try and uh train a crane as you
remember there was the train train the
crane uh caravan yeah well they did not
only cranes but other uh
birds you know and also other uh mammals
in fact and uh
but they never could quite get the crane
to work so they did just bring in a
mechanical mechanical crane okay great
that's brilliant yeah that is a great
moment if you could read that down yeah
um
mine would be
it's very simple
um and it is just a shot
and it's also quite homoerotic
i like yeah carry on
i like the moment in i believe
it's the two towers but it might be
returning the king but i think it's the
two towers
where aragorn has had a hell of a time
and he got thrown off a cliff and then
he almost drowned and then his horse
picks him up and he ends up
in
is it edoras and the doors that he's
trying to get through a massive no one's
helping him out clearly he's at a rough
time covered in a horse
yeah soaking wet
and he has to push these doors on his
own no one's going to
and the light casts an amazing glow on
him and his hair's all wet and he's got
bits of horse feces on in the cracks in
his of his neck and he probably stinks
to high heaven but my god
he looks like a dreamboat and that is an
amazing shot in that trilogy
and do you know uh
vigo tries to recreate that entrance uh
wherever he's going now he'll he'll
always arrive with a huge light that he
places behind him and he always tries to
push two doors at the same time yeah and
he's never been as good as he was that
day but he always he always keeps trying
to chase it you know
um
it's good it's good really that's a good
question i like that let's see uh let's
see if there's another give us another
one
come on johnny cloose
hi billy dom how you guys doing
first of all i want to say i'm a huge
fan dom i love wild things i think i
binge that in a day and billy the last
goodbye that song still gives me
goosebumps man top door mate
yeah so i'm mark with a seat
i'm from all the way across the atlantic
on a little island between england and
ireland called the isle of man
as we all know billy's character pippin
finds the palantir and the two towers
my question for you both is if you could
each look into the sea in stone and see
a perfect world in your own eyes what
would it be you'd see thanks a lot guys
have a good one now
great the island manny dumb you ever
been to the island man no i've never
been an island man um
have you been to the isle of dogs i love
dogs i love lucy
i've never been there with dogs have you
been in the way
and i've not been to any isles it seems
i've not been to sky
uh orkney love to go to orkney
i like the island we used to go to the
isle of man
uh sort of every year really that was
our sort of holiday sometimes
we go to the man and the thing that used
to give me the fear of dom
my dad told me if you misbehave on the
ella man this is when i was uh
you know seven eight years old
they had a thing called the birch
which was a loud nail a man but not the
rest of britain and it was like
little twigs all
together a birch
and they would beat you on your bare bum
if you if you if you broke the law in
the isle of man and i used to be here
getting the birch i never got that back
still good for you
uh was that a classic isle of man accent
there or was it isle of wight he was
from
that sounded to me and more like
somewhere near where you are
is that not like a manchester united
sort of thing scouser or that's what it
felt like to me a little bit anyway we
should answer your man's question uh
yeah yeah please what does paradise look
like i mean i think without any
fear of
health
repercussions
um you know it doesn't matter what you
eat you can just you can just eat it
you're not gonna get fat it's not gonna
kill you
i would say paradise just looks like an
endless road
of nutella sandwiches and sour sweets
i think you should do that from now on
if that's your if that's your idea of
the perfect world i think that's that's
accessible that's accessible do you just
know well yeah but wouldn't isn't it
isn't it bad for you if i were to just
live on uh nutella sandwiches and sour
sweets i would i would probably die
sooner than i
should i don't know i'll give it to the
end of the year see how it goes see how
you feel
um
right
i think
i'm going to say
you know i think and i know it's a
cliche but a world without wardrobe and
i i think that is also accessible
like uh like a road of nutella
i think it's accessible and i think
the history of human beings has always
been about division isn't it's always
been
you're this and weird that and there's
something human beings like that they
like being part i'm part of this group
and we hate that group so we're going to
have a war with you
so i think for me would be to get rid of
all of that there is no was in them
there's only us
and then you know and i think that will
happen at some point
you know maybe not probably not in our
lifetime but at some point there won't
be an as in them they'll just be on us
and
that would be the sort of perfect world
i think
that's a beautiful uh sentiment it's
interesting right because the idea of us
and them on planet earth happens a lot
um but i think
one of the ways that they've said we can
create a sense of all of us being the
same thing is to have a common
them like if a if an alien species shows
up and starts causing a ruckus with
earth then everyone in earth is all in
the same boat and we're all one people
but until that point happens maybe we
won't see it that simple which is a
shame yeah
yeah
it's just the way it's always been but
it'd be good you know and i think we
will get rid of it at some point but who
knows when
reserve bar is the online source of
premium and luxury spirits wine and
champagne
visit reservebar.com to create the
perfect home bar or have the ideal gift
delivered it's also where you'll find
the best in new and hard to find bottles
and those celebrity spirits that you've
been wanting to try no one does spirits
gifting better than reserve bar have a
bottle custom engraved with a name date
or logo to create the perfect gift and
you can also build your dream home bar
at reserve bar just select the spirits
wine and bubbly you love they've also
got glassware and mixing tools should
you need them visit reservebar.com today
and use promo code onion to save ten
dollars off your purchase of 75 or more
on spirits wine or pre-made cocktails
but only when you use our special offer
at reservebar.com
with code
onion that's reservedbar.com
and code onion this offer expires
december 31st 2021
this podcast is sponsored by better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals better help will
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is professional counselling
done securely online there is a broad
range of expertise available which may
not be locally available in many areas
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counselling and financial aid is
available better help want you to start
living a happier life today you can
visit their website and read their
testimonials that are posted daily one
user said my therapist elizabeth has
been extremely helpful and supportive as
i navigate through my healing journey
visit betterhelp.com
onion that's better h-e-l-p and join the
over 1 million people who have taken
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional in
fact so many people have been using
betterhelp that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
special offer for the friendship onion
listeners get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
we're going to go to emails we've got an
email here from liv
lovely live in oregon it's not live
tyler though she does mention live tyler
here in her email and she says
hey billy and dom i am olivia from
oregon new oregon sometimes say oregon
which sounds very lotr to me and i wish
that's how we pronounced it but it's
or again
i was born in 2001 the year the
fellowship came out my parents are
massive florida rings fans before the
before the release of the film when they
heard liv tyler would be in it my mom
decided to name me olivia as a nod to
the actress with the intention of
calling me live i am live to all my
friends and family question if you could
create your own fantastical land based
on your favorite place or where you grew
up
what would it be what would you call it
[Music]
who's going first on this one dumb i can
give a very quick answer here which is
which is a real answer go on then
i'm a massive fan of costa rica costa
rica is a very thin
uh central american country which has
two very distinct coastlines on either
side very different coastlines on either
side and very different
mountainous areas and forested areas and
very very humid areas very dry areas
very varied areas up and down the
country
tons of jungle tons of protected
areas of conservation they don't have an
army they are self-sustainable they're
one of for me the most impressive
countries in the world and if i got
myself into a situation where i thought
okay i'm gonna go disappear for a year
or so i think costa rica would be at the
top of my list and i would call it
costa rica
it's a fantastic name and a fantastic
place to spend your time
right i think i've i've got i've got
quite back into them a surfing dom right
because my son has taken it up and uh so
we we go to the ocean quite a lot again
and i sort of left that for about 10
years or maybe maybe more even i don't
know
but and if i had the perfect place
then it would have a lovely wave
that was just about you know
three or four feet
just and a nice long right hander and i
could just surf that whenever i wanted
and it never got big and messy and it
never disappeared and got like flat it
just always this perfect wave
that landed on a beach that had an ice
bar
with free food
and free beer
and
i had a little garage with all my
electric
bikes and and cars in it
that i could take wherever i want and
just have a nice time all day and i
would call that
billy land
brilliant would you like to visit billy
i'd love to come stay at billy land that
sounds fantastic
yeah well you're always invited there's
always an open door you have a house
there
yeah don't worry about that you've got a
three-bedroom house buying front garden
nice i think i have a house so you said
you've got a long right and there's a
bar there i think i have a house yeah
just as the right ends
kind of diagonal to that on the corner
of a bluff i have a house so if you want
to get out and go to the bar great and
after you've gone to the bar and had
some food you can then walk off and see
your mate dom and every beer while the
sun goes down and the great thing about
your house and billy land if you'll
remember
is you
on on the balcony of your house at the
front there is a talking iguana yeah
he'll tell you everything that's been
going on and billy land well you've been
off doing whatever you're doing in costa
rica brilliant we've got another
question do you want to read this one or
shall i right wait till you hear it
tommy you ready from ashley e and
cincinnati that's in ohio
now don't tell me where in my hand if my
hand was america is ohio i'm gonna say
right
just here on the on on the heel of your
hand here
around here
well hold on so this is california
mexico's down here here's new york
just go to your heel and go across a
little bit so kind of yeah go across
stop right there
there yeah oh yo
i think that's not bad tom good guess
right thanks first says ashley eve from
cincinnati
first i love you both so so much
isn't that a nice thing to hear that
billy i met you when you came to
comic-con in cincinnati and you are one
of the loveliest humans of all time
that's nicer for me here than you yeah
it is actually
if you ever want to try a food that is
uh cincinnati you got to try
pueta
g-o-e-t-t-a
coweta okay now she says actually says i
would love to know
what is the best advice you've ever been
given
professionally
or personally
carry on don
best piece of advice
the best piece of professional advice
that probably came
via
constantine stanislavski and through
my acting teacher at college aquinas
college in uh stockport greater
manchester if anyone's out there
was the acting was listening which i
guess is con is stanislavski's most
famous kind of comment about acting
isn't it um yeah so i
tend to keep that in mind
whenever i'm working that it's not about
what you're saying it's about how you're
reacting to the scenes which make you
say what you're saying so if you can
concentrate on the listening more than
anything else you're probably going to
be
better at acting
it's it's not acting it's reacting love
that don't
i thought that was quite good i think i
summed that up there for you
now
i i'll take one from acting as well i'll
take this one from shakespeare
and he said to thy known self be true
and i think i think that's very
you know as as not just for acting but
you know for for your own life i think
the closer you can get to
being true to yourself
and not try to conform to what everybody
wants then that's the the happier you
will be you know yeah
how's that love it brilliant brilliant
answer
um
all right here's a question you were
being true to yourself there bills which
is a beautiful thing
um
is it is a question from ann
anthony sometimes pronounced anthony
which is fine
uh in texas
who says
dear dumb and billy
if the tv show survivor hosted a season
with the cast of lord the rings who do
you think would come out on top
well
well i think most people from watching a
movie would jump straight to vigo yeah
and say you know he's a survivor
but that you know that was a part that
he played
i'll tell you who would win survivor
though
any i've got no i'd i know this to be
true
it would be you job 100
you can survive in a desert a jungle
up a tree down a hole
middle of the earth on the moon
there's nowhere i couldn't see you
surviving though
well i do love the tv show survivor it's
probably my all-time favorite uh reality
tv show of all time it's my it's not
even a guilty pleasure because i don't
feel guilty about watching it is one of
my pleasures in life is watching the tv
show survivor in fact when i get back
from dublin to the united states there
is a full season of survivor waiting for
me and i just i just can't wait i can't
wait um
i so i know all the nuances of how you
win that game i've become friends with
boston rob over the years i'm friends
with jeff probst who hosts the show
there is the game which is obviously the
assault course and eating certain foods
and swimming in underwater adventure
places and then there's also the game
within the game which is the social game
and i think
i am
probably pretty well versed
on both of them the thing the thing that
i've realized about me over the years
which i think is one of the ways that i
can survive in those situations is i
don't need a lot of things really do
what i mean i don't eat a lot of food i
don't create a massive
footprint in terms of my presence in
places
i'm not
you know i don't i'm not addicted to
anything in particular or have cravings
for anything in particular if i can make
sure that i'm
hydrated and get just a tiny little bit
of food inside me i'm i'm relatively
sustainable you know so
um
yeah i think i do all right i don't know
about winning it but i think i would
definitely be kind of in the
in the final four
oh absolutely absolutely good
hey it's riddle time one of our favorite
times on the show
i know oh how we going to do this week
john well let's see all right come on
who's going to do the riddle first come
on johnny clues are you there all right
you ready for this
right let's do it yeah this is from aunt
concentrate dog
this is from anna h in finland
i am the beginning of everything
the end of everywhere
i'm the beginning of eternity
the end of time and space
what am i
i'm the beginning of eternity the end of
time and space
i've got it done wait i think i think i
have it too
three okay two
one
how come he went three two one and then
you didn't say it no i said it i went e
that was too easy all right this one's a
little harder no that was the second one
another one
all right this is from spencer in
detroit michigan
where is detroit michigan this is
california that's new york
mexico i'm gonna say almost to the very
end of your wedding finger
yeah right about there ish
that's exactly right that is
that could not be more wrong what you
talking about johnny close
it's a little off so i'm trying to be
nice
i know what detroit is all right let's
see more like
it's more various all right all right so
right now i love the show huge fans
start listening to hear bill and don
talking with fellow cast members i love
the format and fun conversations
and i have a riddle for you too
this one's a little tricky
a man lives on the 45th floor of his
building
every morning
gets in the elevator and takes it to the
first floor
he catches a cab and goes to work every
evening he gets back from work gets in
the elevator and takes it to the 20th
floor
he then takes the stairs the rest of the
way through his apartment
describe this man
disgrace drive him
tell me about him
i think i think i might do it
i think i might have heard this before
so i i'm going to leave this one with
billy cause i think i know it
oh i don't i do that's good i don't know
what so i can
bounce things off you dog
so he lives in the 45th floor
he goes to work every day
and then when he comes home so he gets
off at the first floor which is
groundbreaking
for americans right first floor and then
he goes to work he comes back gets on at
the first floor again
but goes up to the 20th
why
why would he do such a silly silly thing
he
is he is he like an elevator engineer or
something
no he might be
no i mean maybe i guess he could yeah
maybe he does leave the building and he
goes to operate
elevators but that might be a challenge
that might be challenging does does he
does he ha
so in the morning he gets soft
so it's not like does he visit someone
on the 20th
maybe has he get two lives has he
married twice
is he a a polygamist
uh no
so it's not like he
he goes and sees his first wife on the
45th and his other wife's on the twitter
he might but that's not relevant
he might have a wife on the 20th
what would he let me
all the way down to the ground floor
every day but only be able to make it to
the 20th floor and walk
25 floors up to the 55th
he's he's a very short man he's a hobbit
he can't reach the 45th that's it
thank you dominic that was a fantastic
clue we solved that together he's a
hobbit he was a hobbit he's amazing
brilliant i love it
that was a good one good good riddle two
good rhythms i hadn't had the first one
either had you heard the first one what
was the first one again no i've not
heard the first one but i did think it
was relatively uh easy to solve the
second one i think i've heard when i was
a little kid uh so i didn't
um guys i feel like maybe johnny clues
uh helped us with the first one i feel
like his reading of it may be given
darn it thank you for that
thank you they make it too challenging
yeah come on we'll go we've got a lot of
things billy and i love we love getting
riddles so if you have any riddles maybe
it's riddles that we haven't um seen
before or riddles that aren't easy to uh
you know read on the internet because
you know those things might be a little
easier to solve
send us an email send us a voicemail
leave messages all over our youtube page
or wherever you want
um and maybe we'll feature you on the
ship
and i hope you guys did well with the
riddles this week that was that was fun
i like riddles
the media is calling it the great
resignation top talent are leaving jobs
in droves for better companies so how do
you take advantage of it with a hiring
partner that will help you attract the
best people you need indeed is a hiring
partner that gets you what you really
want a short list of quality candidates
as fast as possible because you can do
it all attract interview and hire all at
indeed don't struggle on your own to
find quality candidates indeed can help
you hire the right people right now
indeed partners with you on every step
of the hiring process so you can find
talent with the skills you need through
tools like indeed instant match
assessments and virtual interviews one
of the things i love about indeed is
that it makes hiring all in one place so
easy and with indeed instant match over
90 percent of employers get quality
candidates as soon as they sponsor the
job post according to indeed data get
started right now with a 75 sponsored
job credit to upgrade your job post at
indeed.com
that's 75
credit indeed dot com slash onion
indeed.com
onion offers valid through december 31st
terms and conditions are planned need to
hire
you need indeed
now that those winter evenings are upon
us tom there's nothing i like better
again some friends around a nice warm
fire and a smoker's fire pit from solo
stove makes those outdoor evenings even
better and with solar stoves black
friday sale you can get a great deal on
a solo stove fire pit yeah my favorite
thing about my solo stove is just how
portable it is so you can have a little
kind of cozy affair with your family one
evening and then you can pick it up the
next day when it's cooled down take it
to another part of your garden and just
create a completely different vibe i
absolutely love it i tell you what else
i love about it dom it's so easy to
light just a couple of bits of starter
and your fire is blazing in minutes and
it's perfectly portable you can take
solo stove anywhere you go down to the
beach camping it's fantastic shop solo
stoves best deal of the year during
their black friday sale now through
november 28th and get 10 off with promo
code onion plus a lifetime warranty and
free 30-day returns get an extra 10
off black friday deals at solostove.com
[Music]
eat the world and what are we eating
this week dom billy we're eating what i
think is probably outside of
chocolate hazelnut spread my all-time
favorite spread on the planet the
original
marmite
well dominic
how much did that cost you where you
where you are just now no actually
probably about
three euros four euros something like
that
how much you think it is in america
dollars but it's expensive is it more
like seven or eight euros
fifteen
fifteen dollars
fifteen dollars for a jared marmiton
i don't even know if i like it
i don't even know if i like it i i don't
remember if i've ever tried it i don't
think you have we're gonna get into this
in a second i've made my all-time
favorite sandwich which is a cheese and
marmite sandwich and i'll talk you
through that i know we've talked about
this on the show before but um
please please before we do there's an
article from the bbc called the uh the
history of marmite
that has some amazing points here and
i'm just going to read one of them here
it says marmite the original not to be
confused with all the pretenders out
there was invented by accident in the
late 19th century german scientist
justice lee big discovered brewer's
yeast could be concentrated bottled and
eaten in 1902 the marmite food company
was founded in burton on trent
staffordshire where the raw material was
readily available from the town brewers
because obviously burn on trent was full
of beer making uh breweries the original
recipe contained salt spices and celery
later folic acid vitamin
uh b12
firemen and
riboflavin riboflavin
vitamins which occur naturally in some
foods were added in high concentrations
to create the iconic
marmite
tell me about your ceramics dom
oh god william i don't even know where
to begin i'm so excited
what we've got here now a couple of a
couple of little um
i would say issues because it's not
perfect i'm not at home making this
sandwich where it would it would be
perfect
the bread is okay and it's about as
brown as you can get in ireland as you
can see there's some seeds and some nuts
and stuff i'd like my bread to be a
little browner a little kind of
maltier you know um but it's okay inside
this sandwich we have
irish butter because obviously we're in
ireland we have mature irish cheddar
we have rocket which i think is known as
arugula in the united states is that
right yes yes
we have a little slight
dash of lemon juice
we have
quite a lot of marmite spread over the
bread and then i'm going to finish it
off
once we're able to eat it
with some crunchy salt and vinegar
crisps and that is what you call a
classic marmite and cheese sandwich
well maybe you can help me here dom
because i wasn't sure how to prepare it
so what i've done is i've got myself a
little plate and i've got some toast on
it i toasted the bread i've got some
your basic cheddar
i've got butter and of course i've got
the aforementioned marmite yeah so what
would you suggest i do to try it for the
first time i would say as as someone
that's never had
marmite or someone without too much
experience of marmite
i would spread it over your bread
similar to the way that maybe a painter
might put his first or her first
brushstroke of paint on a canvas just a
a a slight
dusting across the bread you want it to
be a hint of marmite it's not not
layered across you know
so that's going on first on without
butter or anything no butter
my toast is now buttered
there's much butter no mermaid that's
just that's just your own personal
preferences as much butter as you want
and then just uh gotcha just a hint i'd
put about
the size of a
the size of a 20 pence piece
on you on your knife
it's that's quite a lot but okay enjoy
yourself maybe half that but that's all
right enjoy it
and then yeah let's have a look good
good just a hint yeah
okay it's just a hand look that looks
like a little bit more than a hint but
that's that's all right that's all right
i'll scrape some of that off and stick
it on another bit
lovely
i'm gonna have it i'll put that in that
edge they're done
i feel like butter spread on too much
too
something like that wasn't it ian
homestead
has bilbo oh yeah butcher's spread over
too much bread now you're gonna give it
a go i'm gonna i'm gonna buy it into my
sandwich because i can barely i can
hardly wait
don't
shall i put cheese on it i'll just have
it like this what cheese have you got
have you got a mature cheddary type vibe
just
yeah
yeah yeah put put some of that on there
for sure
that's great with cheese sauna
ready
describe it
the cheese is overpowering at the sec
hold on
oh there you go
oh that's nice no i like hold on dumb
that's salty
hmm yeah
oh why did you why did i never have this
that's bad right right
there is a there is a kind of an
umami vibe to marmite
yeah
oh i like that no
right
i'm so happy you like it
now hmm why did i never have that
marmite is known
for being
an extremely polarizing taste
in fact
the the ad campaigns for marmite that
have been running for years certainly
since i was a kid
is
marmite
you'd love it or hates it and there
really isn't anything in between you're
either like me
an absolute marmite card-carrying fan
i've got a marmite t-shirt i travel with
marmite i love i can't say more nice
things about marmite i'm a huge marmite
fan and then there are people out there
that can't have it in their house i hate
the smell of it they're not into it you
seem to be one of the converted bills
i think i'm going to be a hundred
percent fan of this stuff i can't
believe i've never had it before
that's fantastic assuming i first smelt
it when i owned them
it really reminded me of bothering
yeah have you have you had a ball right
above row
you know that drink
is it made from the same stuff is it
same similar i think bovrel has more of
a kind of have you ever
thinner
gravy type vibe and i think bovrel is
non-vegetarian whereas not only is uh
marmite vegan uh vegetarian it's also
vegan
no
can you make a drink from mermaid yeah
you can do it like above i think bob
roll's better for the drink
well i may try that oh don't i like that
a lot that is fantastic no i'll tell you
dom
do you know where the name comes from
marmite the name comes
from a french casserole dish
called marmite or actually pronounced
marmite
and the normandy port of diet a popular
fish stew
is known as marmite
ever since the 1920s the red and yellow
label on the jar of mermaid has a
picture of my meat on it as you can see
tom if you're watching on youtube
so yeah
it's a french it's named after a french
casserole dish fantastic absolutely
fantastic you and i
have spent quite a lot of time
in new zealand
and in australia
and one of the things one of the raging
debates in those countries
is
that their version of marmite is
better now let's just reiterate the
english or british version
is the original
and the greatest and over in new zealand
and australia companies like sanitarium
and well-being company sells their own
marmite but has added
caramel and sugar to the original
version giving it a much sweeter taste
so
it deviates from the the original
marmite not only in taste but
inconsistency
and also australia is famous for
creating another kind of bastardization
of marmite which is called
vegemite
i've heard of that one
john i absolutely love it i'm so happy
it's and it says on the thing it's rich
in b vitamins as well so that's energy
and stuff isn't that's good
don let's give him some scores okay
we're going to give it some scores that
this um i'm going i'm going to continue
to eat my sandwich while we give it some
scores
um
first up is flavor i have a tiny bit
more where do you even begin it's it's a
complex flavor i would say full of
complexities um
shall i go first on flavor
yeah go hands on well
the taste of marmite reminds me of being
a student of not having that much money
of living on marmite and toast
sandwiches
marmite and cheese sandwiches maybe
stirring some marmite into my baked
beans
it's the best of english flavors
for me
yeah i mean this is it's going to blow
your mind these scores but for me the
taste of marmite
it's a solid 10. i can't give it
anything less it's a 10 out of 10.
done that's your second ten in two weeks
last week i think you gave a ten as well
you know dennis got a ten so i've never
known anything like it hold on
i went i've went deeper into the mermaid
tunnel
i put a lot more
on this
oh yeah
it's intense from well as a relative
to to to the world of marmite
just tell me
instinctually without being influenced
by any outside sources explain the
flavor to me tell me what what what are
the things coming up when you taste it
so it's very intense to the point that
it's making me make a face
that's so sort of
it's not sour
but it's um
it's affecting my whole system
um i definitely gotta talk strangely for
a vegan thing it's got it's got
like a meat it's almost like a
really intense gravy
it's
oh
um
salty
like almost like um
um what's those little salty hairy fish
anchovies
hello
gum welcome
and it's kind of an anchovy yeah but not
really but the feeling of it's like i
love it you know what john i'm going to
give it
because it's so strange and not really
like any other flavor
i'm going to give it a
9.6 wow
wow
i mean
can you believe i'm that's not part of
my life oh you're gonna love it i just
i'm so excited by the fact that you're
gonna be having marmite on toast for
breakfast and stuff like that it's just
brilliant it it is extremely salty like
i think the overwhelming
taste of it is salt but then once you
start to get into some of the subtleties
of the flavor there is that umami type
taste to it i just yeah i absolutely
love it i love it um
okay right so that's good what about the
look of it dom the look of it i can't i
don't even know where to begin
you've got the you've got the classic
kind of
honey um you know kind of honey
receptacle
shape like a honey barrel type thing
well as as i've already explained to you
that's a french casserole called the
meat the man meat
obviously the color of the jar
so you've got this dark you know brownie
almost guinness type color which
juxtaposes beautifully
with this
uh yellow top this
sticker on the front has been you know
used by bands
as they're kind of um you know they'll
change the name here for the name of
their band but they'll include the kind
of iconic marmite design and then inside
i mean that's it looks very strange
look i'm almost finished with mine i've
only had a couple of weeks
i've just started my dog
oh the smell is i actually bought this
for you i bought this for you a few
months ago and i forgot to give you keep
it because i saw it in the store
yeah i'm going to keep i'm going to eat
it now i would be more than delighted
with the idea that in buying me a gift
you accidentally became a marmite fan
that would just fill me with joy for me
the look the aesthetic the whole thing
it's a 10 out of 10.
two things that
dumb this is unheard of
i will give it because i was i was i was
impressed by your um
discussion there and how you
uh talked about it and it's it's made me
think that that's going to be an 8.8
you're giving a you get you've made me
give it a good mark now i'd like to say
how useful is it um how useful you've
already mentioned maybe when you were a
student you would use it a lot you put
it on toast you stick it in your baked
beans it so it sounds like it's useful
but maybe you could uh
confirm that for me billy thank you the
the classic way to eat marmite is mama
on toast that's the whole kind of
studenty thing but mama is a great
thickening agent in things like gravies
in bologneses in chiles as we've seen
with uh my
treat that i've got here it goes really
well on a cheese sandwich it goes well
with other things on a sandwich you can
stir it into your baked beans which i do
so i make beans on toast i put some
marmite on the toast stir a little bit
of marmite into the beans and a little
bit of curry powder and now you've got
curried beans on marmite on toast
it works in so many different ways
it's extremely versatile
i don't think you can put it in cakes
it's more of a savory thing but marmite
do make uh things like marmite
uh cheese crackers and marmite crisps
marmite
uh cashew nuts marmite rice cakes it's
extremely versatile you're not gonna
believe this it's a 10
for usefulness
dumb
that is a 10 10 10. it's a perfect score
that is unheard of perfect score it's a
perfect score it is the perfect food for
you we have maybe that's the end of
billy and dom eat the world
we have found the bit now it's have to
be perfect for both of us
true and i can't comment on how
useful this is because i haven't tried
it on anything except some toast and
cheese and i absolutely loved it but i
will try it and all the things you're
talking about i love baked beans though
so i will try it in beans
so at the moment i'll give it
just because you see it as
i'll see a 7.8
lovely stuff for marmite i would say
when you're making it with your baked
beans bills as a novice don't overwhelm
it i would say
half a teaspoon of marmite in your baked
beans as you're doing it but the other
thing which i think you would really
like if you're making a
if you're making a stew or a casserole
or a or a chili or a bolognese and you
taste it you're just like i just just
need something it needs a little kick it
needs a little punch you just need
something just to put it over the edge a
teaspoon of marmite in there just brings
it all together it's amazing it's
amazing
i will keep i'll keep you informed how
i'm using it because i really love it
though and it leaves a nice aftertaste
in your mouth it's actually taking me
back to my childhood when you used to be
able to get overall crisps
you know or america chips you would get
borrowed flavor and it's left that i
feel as if i've just had a packet above
real christmas yes well i'll leave you
with this final quote here from
nutritionist
melanie brown
who says mama plays such a useful part
in many people's diet and it's
incredibly useful for older people who
are sure of vitamin b12 it's full of
folic acid and there is evidence that
many women especially young women of
child bearing age are deficient in folic
acid so young ladies
should be eating marmite shouldn't we
all
that's good to hear i mean it's nice if
you
if you like the flavor of something and
then some nutritionalist says it's
actually good for you that's even better
oh dom you've really switched me on
today that's maybe the best thing you've
ever told me about and i've never
listened up to this point
you should have told me more forcefully
that is that is absolutely delicious i
love that you can lead a horse to water
but you can't make it eat marmite um but
i'm so glad that you tried it and you
enjoyed it and you're right i think we
have peaked because i've never look i
think a couple of weeks ago i gave
guinness a 10 out of 10 fresh eggs but i
didn't give it a 10 out of 10 for flavor
and usefulness but marmite gets a
perfect 30 out of 30 score so yeah
marmite
that is unbelievable we need to in the
new studio have a mermaid poster or
something as our first perfect store
[Music]
dom can we do funky for you because we
haven't done that for a few weeks now
and i like listening to music and
commenting let's do it introduce our
funky song this week
we may need
um
johnny close to help us out here johnny
[Music]
uh
[Music]
okay
thanks john kind of came out of left
field
done
so i tell you do you know who that was
don quinn do you know who that music was
tell me bills tell me about this song
well marley's from alberta canada
says that she really likes is it funky
she likes that segment of the show she
said it's a great way to hear about new
tunes and listen to your favorites
that's true and you can get you can
listen to all of this on the friendship
onion on spotify if you go onto spotify
you'll find our thing there and it's got
all the songs on it you'll love it
anyway she suggested a song by five
alarm
funk it's an awesome band from vancouver
canada
and they put on the best shows and are
described as a horn
powered percussion fueled sonic and
visual
assault were you assaulted by their
phonics sonic and visual assault dom i
felt very assaulted but in a good way
can we hear it one more time johnny
come on johnny give us the funk
i'm gonna wash your
[Music]
face one
[Music]
i get [ __ ] up all the time
wow
dumb
i don't think we can deny that that's
funky
quite aggressive funk wasn't it yeah i
think i'd like to see that band um live
i think as they say they're known for
their kind of sonic and visual assault
they're called five alarm funk and that
track is called wash your face
there you go though wash your face yeah
i washed my hands and face before i came
out i loved it
so
do you want to give it a score in a sort
of band tell us again how the the scores
work on this though yes thank you these
scores are rated in funk level from
brahms
no funk
all the way up to as sexy as he gets
prince
very funky
right tom i'm gonna give that because
that was funky and it was yeah it was
like
it was as you see it was a kind of
aggressive
lots of stabs horns
you were talking about prince there and
i'm going to say
prince i'll uh
sign the times around that time when it
was a bigger band lots of stabs and yeah
like earthquake that sort of thing
love it
i'm gonna give it because there was a
level of aggression and kind of dance
element to
uh that song by farvalam funk i'm gonna
give it
i can turn a corner funk is that
sorry
um
that level of funk
uh fantastic stuff i absolutely loved it
i love this world thank you for sending
that on i love it when people get the
bands wrong the names
tell that story of what your uncle used
to call a famous band
do you remember this i'm sure it was an
uncle and he was talking to you about a
band for a while and you're like oh i do
know it i don't know that band yeah
my uncle paul
uh
was trying to get me into a band for i
don't know a good a good couple of weeks
but it's like have you heard that jammy
rocky do you know in that jammy rock
he's brilliant and i was like jammy
rocky no i don't know he's like oh he's
everywhere he's all over england and
he's massive he's having like big hits
in europe he's brilliant tammy rocky
look him up jamiroquai jamiroquai
jamie jamie rocky
close
dom
i think we're going to have to leave it
there this week on that note if you
don't mind i loved it
you've introduced me to mermaid which i
absolutely loved it this week it was
great fun but for that alone it was
worth it that is so delicious i was
licking the knife i was looking to
mermaid from the brilliant dog
well delicious
thanks a lot to everyone who's been
listening and possibly watching today we
really appreciate your support we
appreciate all the comments that you're
leaving on our um
youtube channel and also wherever you
pick up your podcast and if you want to
give us
a five star review and leave lovely
comments it always helps us to make more
and more podcasts so thank you and bless
you you guys for doing that and also if
you want to get a hold of any cool
merchandise
you can go check them out
at the friendship onion.com
the
friendshitonionpodcast.com
thanks for catching it
it looks good on youtube i tell you what
yeah thanks to everybody don't forget
rate
subscribe review do all of that we'll
see you next week on the friendship
onion toodles
[Music]